- Well get ready, because
our next guest is one
of America's top psychic
mediums and his readings
will definitely raise the
hairs on the back of your neck.
His new...I hope I'm not too hairy.
That just sounds...that's
a weird thing to say.
Anyway, his new book, "When Heaven Calls,"
comes out in March and here it is
looking all good and fly.
And he has a new reality show on E
called "Meet the Frasers."
Take a look.
- Growing up being psychic
was not easy for me.
I tried my hardest to
push this ability away,
but I went to go to see
a medium about a girl
that I liked, about all the
normal teenage questions,
and instead, I left hearing
that I was a medium.
Hold on, I'm listening.
I actually had to leave
my full time job as an EMT
because I realized I could use
this ability to help people,
just in a different way.
(applauding)
All right, y'all, please
welcome Matt Fraser!
(audience applauding)
(lively music)
(music drowns out speech)
Have a seat.
- Thank you.
- I love this!
Okay so wait, here's my question,
'cause people watch
reality TV and I'm like,
how real is reality TV,
'cause there's cameras there,
so that's not real, right?
- Well listen--
- How real?
- (laughing) Here's both
the good and bad parts.
So I'm on season one so
I didn't know any better
than to just act myself.
I didn't know.
- Oh please keep doing that.
Don't be weird, like other...yeah.
- I didn't know how much of
it would be on TV or whatever.
They said, "Okay, ignore the cameras.
"Just go about your daily business."
So, you know, I went
about my daily business.
I was on the bidet, I'm
getting into my man space.
(laughing)
Little did I know, wait a
minute, wait a minute now,
little did I know that this
was gonna end up on TV.
(laughing)
- Oh my god, I actually want to
be such good friends with you.
Like the fact that you...that is.
I talk about my Spanx
all the time, so openly.
It's so great!
- Yeah, but I'm a man.
(laughing)
- Who cares?
I know men that wear Spanx.
- Well listen, I didn't know
that the Spanx community--
- Yeah.
- For men--
- Was like,
like once you say--
- That was under ground.
(laughing)
It was easier to come out as
a medium than a Spanx man.
- It was easier to come out as a medium...
That's what she said.
- Oh my god.
- So wait, I do have a question, though.
So you're here, so you're here.
Are you feeling anything now?
- Yeah, it's crazy,
'cause when I look out into the audience,
all I see and hear is dead people.
I feel like I'm connecting...
- Oh my god, it's like
the move "Sixth Sense."
You're that boy.
- It is.
I feel like I'm connecting
with the funeral home
because all these souls
that are here, you know,
trying to speak and trying to connect.
And first of all, your mom departed.
Your mom's standing right next to you.
Can I get up?
- What, what?
- Your mother's right here.
The way that it works for
me is that when I'm in
a room or I'm in an area,
all of your souls will try
to come through and speak and
she was just standing next
to you and saying, "That's my
daughter, that's my daughter.:
So know it's your mom's
way of just acknowledging
that you're here and letting
you know that she is okay.
This was a woman who had
suffered before her passing here
in the physical world.
- Yes.
- 'Cause what happens is,
Kelly, that they'll put me back
in their body to show me what had gone on.
And they'll stand next to
you to show you they're here
and she showed me she couldn't breathe
before she had passed.
- Yes, she was on a ventilator.
- I feel like I'm drowning
when I'm connecting with her.
- What?
- Yeah, she had a heart attack.
I was in the emergency room.
She was 62 years old.
- Your mom says to me that, first of all,
she wants to thank you for
keeping a promise to her.
She says you promised her
that you weren't gonna leave
her side because she was afraid.
And she says, do you know
that my daughter stayed
with me all night long and
you laid on the side of her
and you laid with her and
your mom just wants to say
thank you so much for allowing my soul
to go to the other side.
- Yeah.
- Can I give you a hug?
(audience applauding)
- Is that real?
Mind-blown that he even
knew all those details
is so creepy and awesome.
I am so glad I don't
see dead people, though,
so please dead people,
if you're in the room,
I can't handle it.
(audience laughing)
Just so you know.
So Matt's new book, "When Heaven
Calls," comes out in March.
Here it is.
He's calling everybody on this.
And don't miss Matt on "Meet
The Frasers," Mondays on E.
Coming up, we'll meet a couple
who helped foot the bill
for soldiers trying to get
home during the holiday season.
Please stay with us.
(audience applauding)
That is crazy!